so where we left off we I had given you
the question you know it's these these
these type of equations are fairly
straightforward when we have two real
roots then this is the general solution
and if you have your initial conditions
you can solve for C 1 and C 2 but the
question I'm asking is what happens when
you have two complex roots or
essentially when you're trying to solve
the characteristic equation when you're
trying to solve that quadratic the B
squared minus 4ac that that's negative
so you get the two roots end up being
complex conjugates and we said okay
let's say that our two roots are lambda
plus or minus mu I and we just did a
bunch of algebra to sit we said well if
those are the roots and we substitute it
back into this formula for the general
solution we get all of this and we kept
simplifying it all the way until we got
here where we said e is equal to e you
know y is equal to e to the lambda X
plus c1 X etc and we said can we
simplify this further and that's where
we took out Euler's equation or Euler's
formula or Euler's definition depending
what you want which I I'm always in awe
of every time I see it or use it but
we've talked a lot about that in the in
the calculus playlist but we could use
this to maybe further simplify it so I
could wrote e to the MU X I as cosine mu
X plus I sine mu X and I wrote e to the
minus mu X I is cosine minus mu X plus I
sine minus you at MU X and now we could
use a little bit about what we know
about trigonometry right cosine of
cosine of minus theta is equal to cosine
of theta and we also know that sine of
minus theta is equal to minus sine of
theta so let's use these identities to
simplify this a little bit more so we
get Y is equal to e to the lambda x
times and let's see we could actually
distribute the c1 to so times c1 cosine
of MU X plus I times c1 sine
of MU X plus plus all of this is in this
parenthesis right here plus c2 instead
of cosine of negative mu X we know this
identity so we can just write this as
cosine of MU X as well because cosine of
minus X is the same thing as cosine of X
plus C I times c2 sine of minus mu X
that's the same thing as minus sine of X
well actually let's take this let's make
this to take the minus sign out there so
minus sine of MU X and let's see it
seems like we're getting to a point that
we can simplify it even more we could
add the two cosine terms so we get the
general solution and I know this is this
is a hi this problem requires a lot of
algebraic stamina but as long as you
don't give me careless mistakes you'll
find it reasonably rewarding because
you'll see where things are coming from
so we get why the general solution is y
is equal to e to the lambda x times
let's add up the two cosine mu X terms
so it's c1 plus c2 times cosine of MU X
let's add the two sine of MU X terms
so plus I we could constantly call that
c1 I see one I that's that - see - I see
two I times sine of MU X and we're
almost done simplifying and the last
thing we can simplify is well you know C
1 and C 2 are arbitrary constants so
let's just define this as another
constant I don't know let's call it I'll
just call it C 3 I mean just to just to
not confuse you by using c1 twice I'll
call this C 3 and now this might be a
little bit of a stretch for you but if
you think about it really makes sense
this is still just a constant right
especially especially if I say you know
what I'm not restricting this the
constants to the real
see could be an imaginary number so if C
is an imaginary number or some type of
complex number we don't even know
whether this is necessarily an imaginary
number so but you know we're not going
to make any assumptions about it let's
just say that this is some other
arbitrary constant call this C four and
we can worry about it when we're
actually given the initial conditions
but what this gives us if we make that
simplification we actually get a pretty
straightforward general solution to our
differential equation where the
characteristic equation has complex
roots and that I'll do in a new color
that is y is equal to e to the lambda X
e to the lambda X times some constant
I'll call it C 3 it could be C 1 could
be C 100 whatever some constant times
cosine of mu of X plus some other
constant I called it C 4 doesn't have to
be C 4 I just want to confuse it with
these but some other constant times the
sine of mu of X so there's there's
there's really two things I want you to
realize one is we haven't done anything
different at the end of the day we still
just took the two roots and substituted
it and substitute it back into these
equations for R 1 and R 2 the difference
is we just kept algebraically
simplifying it so that we got rid of the
eyes that's all we did there was really
nothing new here except some except for
some algebra and the use of Euler's
formula but when we when we had when
these when R 1 and R 2 involved complex
numbers we got to this simplification so
in general if you get the characteristic
equation and your two roots are mu plus
or minus oh sorry no your two roots are
lambda plus or minus mu I then the
general solution is going to be this and
it's not to you know if you had to
memorize that although I don't want you
to you should be able to derive this on
your own but it's not too hard to think
and actually if you ever forget it just
whenever you know solve your solve your
characters equation get your complex
numbers and just substitute it right
back in this equation and then with the
real numbers instead of the
lambda and mu with the real numbers just
do the simplification we did and you'll
get to the exact same point but if
you're taking an exam and you know you
don't want to waste time and you want to
be able to do something fairly quickly
you can just remember that if I have a
complex root or F complex roots to my
characteristic equation lambda plus or
minus mu I I can just I then my general
solution is e to the lambda X times some
constant times cosine of MU X plus some
constant times sine of MU X and let's
see if we can we can do a problem real
fast that involves that so let's say I
had the the differential equation see Y
prime prime plus the first derivative
plus y is equal to zero so our
characteristic equation is R squared
plus R plus one is equal to zero let's
break out the quadratic quadratic
formula so the roots are going to be
negative B so it's negative 1 plus or
minus the square root of B squared B
squared is 1 minus 4 times AC well a and
C are both 1 so it's just minus 4 all of
that over 2 right 2 times a all of that
over 2 so the roots are going to be
negative 1 plus or minus the square root
of this is negative 3 over 2 or we could
rewrite this as the roots are R is equal
to negative 1/2 plus or minus well we
could rewrite this as I times the square
root of 3 or square root of 3i over 2 or
we could write this as square root of 3
over 2 times I actually that's the best
way to write it write square root of you
just take the I out so it takes the
negative 1 out and you have left with
square root of 3 over 2 so these are the
roots and now if we want the general
solution we just have to throw this
right back into that and we'll have our
general solution so
right that right down here so our
general solution will be y is equal to e
to the real part of our complex
conjugates so e to the minus 1/2 times X
right this is our lambda times some
constant I'll write c1 now c1 times
cosine of of D you could kind of the of
the kind of the imaginary part without
the I so cosine of square root of 3 over
2 X plus c2 times sine of square root
over square root of 3 over 2 X not too
bad we had complex roots and it really
didn't take us any more time than when
we had two real roots you just have to
realize this and then you have to just
find use a quadratic equation to find
the complex roots of the characteristic
equation and realize that this is lambda
this minus 1/2 is lambda and that the
square root of 3 over 2 is equal to MU
and then substitute back into this
solution that we got anyway in the next
video I'll do another one of these
problems and we'll actually have initial
conditions so we can solve for C 1 and C
2 see you in the next video